what's up su boy oh it's another
gameplay video oh how about that baby I
never play games I play games all the
time all the time have you opened your
eyes okay I play games I'm a gamer okay
I'm the best gamer in the world you know
why because I have the most amount of
subscribers yes that's how it works more
subscribers better gaming skills get on
it it's not that hard last episode I
decided to draw a bunch of memes and it
upsets some website that I never heard
about saying that I am now leaning into
my new far-right following because
drawing memes is a political statement
everyone everyone knows that everyone
knows that you can't draw funny pictures
no no no no no that's a political
statement he's making man with that the
world is so [ __ ] stupid what happened
what happened to everyone it even went
viral on tumblr and I was like why that
doesn't make any sense
and I found the source the source is Wil
Wheaton he reblogged it and I know it's
him a big hearty block I'll put it by
Drew he drove the Pepe mean I don't like
it mine look I get it
I don't like cartoon frogs daddy much
either I have a toad it's a shitty pet
like actually you know what it's
justified to avoid any form of
controversy because that would just be
the worst thing ever I am going to draw
this time other people as requested by
you bros now okay why should I draw draw
my will to live well that should be a
blank canvas all right who should I draw
can I get an actual suggestion okay I
can't see anything so I'm just gonna
draw Wil Wheaton just gonna draw
his chubby little face oh come on no
one's bought it yet this game just
pissed me off man I don't get it man
what am I doing wrong
what am i doing wrong in laughs I just
want well wet and to learn me does he
not know about my ramen respect great I
just drew great all right well there he
is let's see how he goes let's see okay
who should we draw an eggs Jake Paul
everybody it's every day bro oh [ __ ]
munch era this tingles my fish in here
okay well will wheaton sold quick I
guess here you go taken he sold for
nothing
and look at the price what the [ __ ]
oh no fam oh no hell no man goddamn it
what is no one would they Crompton
haha it's cute oh [ __ ] we gotta pay the
bills okay let's finish him
there we go it's beautiful I will call
this one we came to a mutual agreement
done it's perfect it's my perfect art
[ __ ] we don't have a lot of money left
with this fellow has no energy well you
didn't watch your videos all right whose
should we draw next well I guess it's
markiplier Stern huh let's do his dark
applier
yes it's called
always drawing teeth makes for great
details look at that looks so much
better now yes beautiful is beautiful I
can't be bought as a fin of this garbage
okay there we go
[ __ ] you know fanfiction crap can we
draw something decent now something more
interesting Jesus Christ pickle record a
spam finally a decent suggestion
fanfiction crap was sold great
it's it's kind of cute you know what
I'll take it
it's a [ __ ] alright there it is [ __ ]
take it just pickle Rick there we go
draw Minyoung from BTS okay sure sure
fam I got you I'm gonna draw the best
goddamn fan art you've ever [ __ ] seen
baby can adjust the Nick Crumpton 1 or
is it just there forever ok I guess they
don't like they don't like pickle Rick
either ok I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm so
sorry
now the thing is if this fan art doesn't
come out perfect I'm going to end my
life life would not be worth living
anymore remember this Felix he has to be
absolutely stunning my whole life
depends on this fan art I'm not joking
it's beautiful
let me just finish off with a low
perfect it's perfect there it is there
it is fan
there you go menu minyan there you go
this one better make me rich [ __ ] with
all these shitty suggestions man ok we
can draw some Papa fan art everyone
everyone is always doing that
I think I'll draw this version let's
begin I'm actually enjoying this is
really fun to draw the choice of color
is a bit too radical the choice of
letting you live it's a bit too radical
ok how about that I'm not afraid to spit
too through family
look at that boy now that's art man
that's [ __ ] out if that's not art I
don't know what I don't even want to
know what artists I want to know what
art is there any way we can make him a
little cuter I feel like oh there it is
there it is there it is yes I feel like
there the art is trying to seduce me I
like it
keep going oh yes it's getting steamy in
here oh yes yeah I actually like it
oh yes it's beautiful I'll call it Fupa
I can't believe knee Crumpton hasn't
sold yet what the [ __ ] this fellow has
no energy [ __ ] off y'all [ __ ] off you
don't know [ __ ] alright who should we
draw on it John Dolan Tucker okay
alright fam I will I shall I shall draw
him with all my might and power you
better watch you [ __ ] duckling you
bet a meme out of this you [ __ ] I
know I'm so mean to you now all the
sudden you're beautiful I think it's
obvious that I clearly stopped trying at
some point here and this one it just
really doesn't look like a duck alright
memes there you go there you go [ __ ] off
hey Ethan sold everybody man ferpa sold
for a lot Jesus
we should we do another nick Crumpton he
looks so sad I really want to capture
his sad soul in this one I feel like
what am i doing what's happening oh my
god an art critic The Critic he's
judging my BTS fan art I see what is the
same that's it that's [ __ ] it [ __ ]
off Mastercraft he called it a master
craft min yo man yo a new way how the
talent I knew I had the towel at mein
all right the next act okay what is that
I mean I'll take it you have unlocked a
new tool maybe I can actually draw
properly now instead of these shitty
ones what about it okay I draw okay
cute so what is this oh it's much more
defined okay I got it
nice oh yes
ah that every stroke makes me want to
stroke it Nick Nick Rampton is the most
beautiful man I've seen I wanna run away
with you Nick Crampton just me and you
Nick Crompton I just noticed your
collars not it's not popping it's not
popping in this picture - we just want
to point that out point that out to
everyone
it's eyes they scream save me tusks it
does get a this summer this collar I'm
gonna make popping for you Nick that's
right look at this
that's popping that was beautiful that
was goddamn beautiful test get to
Buddhist Emma
alright I'll let you guys guess which
one this is
[Music]
it's mine Emma Jeffers Channing Chatham
everyone I really captured it I really
think I captured it quite perfectly I
gotta say I'm very proud of myself like
the ice could probably use a little bit
more work [ __ ] it there it is man named
ed Jaffa that's all for me for now boys
and girls mainly girls of course thank
you for watching me draw this beautiful
art and I see you in the next one stay
is sister Esther